they believed they would meet God they
ended up in a shallow grave outside a
coastal town in eastern Kenya victims of
a suspected cult leader
Abbas ade's wife son and parents-in-law
disappeared leaving everything behind so
when I get to search our phone I said
someone asked them they are going to see
Jesus so then I tracked a flight it's
only broke a one-way ticket to malindi
which she should have a return ticket
back to Nairobi this is the man accused
of luring them to malindi
McKenzie
and the leader of the good
International Church he apparently
promised his followers they would meet
their creator if they starved themselves
to death it was
because there wasn't enough information
enough evidence to you know keep him
behind bars that's what the court said
so yes people are angry but you know
this has gone this far police believe
dozens of victims may be buried in the
forest
several children are among the dead and
there are fears many more could be
missing
we visited homes in villages in the area
and we spoke to parents whose children
had all died some families have lost up
to five children and in some cases the
parents have died as well
some members of the church were rescued
from the preacher's property alive but
weak relatives at the examination site
are holding out hope that their missing
loved ones have survived
so deserting and very inhuman to see
what is going on here odd the people who
have been coming here I can I can see
none of us have seen our relative but we
are just finding red skinned more people
and seeing more griefs
Mackenzie is now in custody Pathologists
are taking samples from the victims to
determine the cause of death Siobhan
silk Al Jazeera